In Iraq, security measures have been reinforced inside Baghdad's Green Zone...
...and Iraqi counterterrorism forces stand guard in front of the US embassy...
...after pro-Iran demonstrators left the area a day after their dramatic incursion.
In Turkey, parliament has authorized the deployment of troops to Libya...
...to support the UN-backed government in a battle for the capital of Tripoli.
At least 17 people in Australia have been declared missing and one has died...
...after fires ripped through East Gippsland, a rural area east of Melbourne,...
...according to an ABC Australia report.
In Taiwan, Air Force General Shen Yi-ming, the country's top military official,...
...was among eight people killed...
...after a helicopter made a forced landing in a mountainous area near the capital Taipei.
Finally from Lebanon, the government received an Interpol arrest warrant...
...for former Nissan boss Carlos Ghosn,...
...as Turkey launched an investigation into his daring escape from Japan via Istanbul.